mais c'est le prof ne redonnera pas chez
chacun une feuille leur dis vous décidez
ce qui vous manque à la maison tout le
monde décide
sauf le petit benjamin le benjamin il
donne une feuille blanche et lunettes
pourquoi tu as donné le faible en chine
où il nous manque rien à la maison mais
tu peux pas dire ça il oblige ai dit non
il nous manque rien du tout à la maison
est dit mais qu'est ce qui fait dire ça
et du bayer ont dîné ma soeur elle est
venue avec un son mec et son est qu'il
est noir et mon père il a dit à il nous
manquait plus que ça les boudeurs
aywaille
là
fait d'autant que c'est le mec au plus
drôle moi qui me fait flipper c'est
qu'il fait penser à quelqu'un dont je
connais mon côté je vois là ya de part
de l'acheteur et nous avons avec nous
bouder qui est avec nous
on dirait parfois un peu lent mais chéri
mecheri regarde télé l'agate agathe
oui ça a marché le truc dingue dans
lesquelles sa marque ses parents que tu
as changé de lunettes à gateway chez
vous du pôle emploi tout je trouve qu'un
gâteau est autant aujourd'hui fait
siffler elle s adresse à 20h10 maire my
arms est bon pour l exercice est bon
tous mourir
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas bouder ce soir vous étiez
moudjahidins khadija en fait toutes les
trois cogneurs
ah ouais mais là les jeunes vont régler
leur foi ce qui comprend qu'il ya un
problème c'est quoi je fais juste mon
cours de tango et je m'occupe de toi
c'est au fait est ce que bon je crois
que j'ai mon professeur 41 mon
professeur de tango
non
je sais pas ce que je dois faire bonjour
sans rentrer avant que tu nous donnes tu
va nous donner dans un instant tu as
marié que tu as trouvé la plus belle et
vous aussi on va voir le résultat des
téléspectateurs juste avant il en reste
une
d'accord c'est la dernière d'alleyras
diffic je vous demande d'applaudir
bouder
[Applaudissements]
j'allume à achat
les rebelles
à chaque fois que je fais une mission je
suis déguisé en oeuvre mais nos élus
motivés le fils de la route sont là bas